supporters of president rook kaburi's
mpp party celebrate
at their headquarters shortly after the
preliminary results of last sunday's
presidential election
were announced the election commission
says president kabor is secured more
than three times
what his closest opponent received there
were 13 other candidates
proclamation after this proclamation mr
cabore
rock christian mark has declared
provisionally elected in the first round
as president of burkina faso with
57.8 percent of the votes in the
election of november the 22nd
the result means kabul has fed the
uncertainty of facing a united
opposition
in a runoff addressing his supporters he
promised an
all-inclusive dialogue to move the
country forward
cabot called the vote historic la
premiere
context first is the context it was held
the insecurity everyone is aware of
secondly it's the first time people of
burkina faso in diaspora participated in
elections
third a confirmation of democracy is
taking firm roots here
the opposition party raised concerns
about the validity of the vote count
and reserved their right to challenge
the results in court
the opposition heard what the election
commission said and is ready to use all
legal means to get justice about all the
irregularities
in the election of november the 22nd we
however reaffirm
all commitment to preserve peace and
stability in burkina faso
by placing the interest of the country
above all consideration
the opposition had hoped for a runoff so
a united opposition could field a single
candidate
they now have a week to challenge the
results in court
more than 1 300 polling stations were
closed in the north and east of the
country
due to fears of violence by groups
linked to al-qaeda
and islamic state the constitutional
court has to ratify the results within
15 days
from the date of the announcement of the
results ahamed idris
al-jazeera